[Music]
foreign
what a big movie was
[Music]
until I came onto this
[Applause]
this movie for me existed elementally
for 20 years
[Music]
it's a story of a few against many
impossible odds good versus evil
I'm getting a chance to tell a story
that I've been thinking about for quite
a while
I was really excited about Zach I just
really value and admire his enthusiasm
for The Craft
he hadn't quite anticipated their
physical requirements of this
[Music]
we had a solid two months of preparing
the body to get to that place I've never
trained that much
I mean it is gargantuan
I just really wanted to make a giant
atmospheric and space adventure it's so
so so big so ambitious we get to
Traverse the darker corners of this
universe we'll have a huge anticipation
for this film it's amazing something so
powerful that you just want more and
it's only the beginning
[Music]
all right
foreign